don't be
I when I boo
al right here Wiz Khalifa place got to
shut it down the first side of your
vegas is your first time first time
before I management I usually just get
ahead of her lungs haha most definitely
man now i gotta say it like you are kind
of on your own level right now you've
gone from you know from online sensation
kinda no problem need to sound out like
everyday on the tour man how you feeling
right now it's feeling good you know it
feels like they wanted me norm store
worker just keeping the jeep yeah
Ceaser's i would like the recycle could
you you had you know that the
situational warner brothers yeah i'll do
some more more control bro I know a
little bit more what's going on I mean
some of the people my back itches really
I'm sorry that's what I'm stretchy it's
all good man let's talk about the doubt
babe you got one who I am I correct yeah
i'm working on oh [__] man it's just fun
to crazy I've been at this airport I do
you have a minute early to try to like
try to squeeze that hahahaha it's gonna
be our
can you guys sit on any any features on
the album and anything yet it's not
anything of stuck in what would you who
who would you like to who is who is kind
of odd i think our goddess i want to get
on how to get on the rapid just keep
that you know but the album is pretty
much done it's amazing my part is crazy
so you know enough we put the find a
little magic on names pick one up yes
sir grind it up I gotta ask you to get
em season just kind of give I thought it
was kind of Shannon to do makeup I
didn't see it you didn't see it oh I've
been on tour oh yeah I think Ryan
haven't been watching no TV i did get to
see my video on MTV winner was generally
I didn't get to see I didn't get the
hero ready right thing so the NTU list
you've just been traveling everything
like mms on our show that any night dog
I they go topless rat they don't follow
since I was Waka Flocka make it no it's
my first time and it's not hard he
doesn't follow Yates make a street using
that one huh / MC MC [__] i missed rap
rap music is that Mars music period is
that version on it so we using just in
making it knows and I just
animals download link whistle if I
appreciate a couple minutes now
appreciate